- [Narrator] This is black ramen.
And this dish in particular
is a five-time national champion.
But its origins came from a restaurant
a few paces down the road.
Here.
(foreign language)
Toyama is a coastal city
in the northeast of Japan.
It is known worldwide for
one thing in particular.
And that is its signature
Toyama black ramen.
(foreign language)
The recipe originated
back in 1947 from one man.
(foreign language)
Traditionally, ramen broth
is made from pork or miso.
When these were not available, Mr. Aoiki
looked to what was around,
and that was soy sauce.
(foreign language)
If you want to try Toyama black ramen,
you have to go to Toyama.
(foreign language)
And one of those is Ramen Iroha,
whose black ramen, as we said earlier,
is often heralded as the
best ramen in the country.
(foreign language)
This signature dish of the region
draws in crowds from around
the country and the world.
And the claim of best ramen in Japan
makes the draw that much more intense.
(foreign language)
(upbeat music)